shooting the car chase in Paris it was  it was me it was me Tom Shawn Harris  Ving Rhames and Henry you just asked him  if you could tell me  [Laughter]  so it's a very cramped car particularly  with Bing and Henry who are both big  guys and me in the middle bombing around  Paris and every time we finished the  shot we have to reset the shot drive  back to the start points we can do it  again Henry has had enough of sitting in  the cramped car so he says are can I run  back I'll run back too because he looked  a bit of running course yeah yeah so  Henry took off and ran back to position  one whereas we and we just drove next to  him going it's one of the coolest  moments of my life is having Tom Cruise  do that driving next year  [Applause]  [Music]  you